well i'm joined now by walter vanuville
who is the climate change adaptation
expert at the european environment
agency good afternoon to you i hope you
have said that name uh correctly so
things are pretty bad aren't they maybe
the worst they've been in ages it's
certainly a serious drought we are
facing now in in many places of europe
and it goes as far as some areas where
even drinking water there's not
sufficient supply for drinking water so
people need to be provided by by trucks
and so on so of course there are many
areas where there are advisors advisers
to to lower the water use but there are
also a lot of places where those things
are already mandatory where farmers
already for weeks are not allowed to to
pump groundwater are not allowed to to
pump water for uh from minor rivers and
so on so yeah it's
serious
let me clarify that point you're talking
about so drinking water has run out has
it from taps
and where uh right around europe
yeah there are some places in europe
where there's not sufficient water
supply uh for drinking water which is
normally let's say the highest priority
uh of of the whole chain of who can use
the the scarce water we have
it's not on a large area because it has
the highest priority but even that is
happening so if if you want to compare
this
for many places of western europe we are
now in a situation that can become
as severe as it was in 1976 or at some
places even even more
yes we've seen the effects haven't we in
recent days and weeks and what is
causing all this simply
a lack of rainfall
um
i think we have a few things together um
a drought is something that doesn't
happen overnight the drought doesn't
happen just become this summer
but it's already raining less than the
long-term average in in many parts of
europe for months so the first half of
this year we had
significantly less rainfall over a large
area and in addition we had some heat
waves so there was a lot of additional
evaporation we all remember the heat
waves of a few weeks ago in july but
there were also already very early heat
waves this year in
in the end of may and beginning of
june in several parts of europe so it's
a combination of of those two things
coming together
yeah and france is going through its
fourth heat wave of the year isn't it is
that unprecedented we're saying that we
in the uk are having our second in three
weeks
yeah waves and and what they mean is a
little bit defined different from
country to country so it's it's very
difficult to compare one heat wave with
another
um when you talk to meteorologists they
often say yeah compared to heat waves
what makes sense is to count the number
of uh
of of tropical days the number of
tropical nights and so on and there you
see
uh we see that 2022 is a summer with a
lot of tropical days is yeah
let's say much warmer than it was uh
over the last
over the long term average for example
in some other countries like the
netherlands and belgium they only have
the first heatwave coming up now
depending to the definitions but that
doesn't in any way give a clear picture
of how june and july were there were
really warm months so rather than just
counting heatwaves which is a little bit
yeah an artificial thing uh if you
really look at the number of of days
above 25 degrees stays above 30 degrees
stays above 35 degrees and so on you
will see records close to records for
many countries and is this the shape of
things to come in the future
well it this is
not the message that this will happen
every year from now on but if you look
over longer periods there's there's
certainly a chance that this will happen
more often that these kind of droughts
will that that were in the past on
average happening once every decade or
once every two decades now will become
yeah more more frequent and several
times per decade so i think indeed this
is more of what is going to happen in
the in the near but also in the midterm
future
and are there small steps that
individuals can take to try to alleviate
the situation
there are many things that people can do
and and that all kinds of businesses can
do as as a drought contrary to the
heatwave is something that is building
up over the months
most of the activity you can do is is
happening way before which means that
when we have a lot of rain and when we
have too much rain it needs to
infiltrate much better in in our soils
in our groundwater reservoirs to be
available in the periods that we have
less rain so that is certainly one of
the key messages we need to make sure
that the water when it is available is
also going through our groundwater
reservoirs is leaking through our soils
rather than just going to our rivers as
fast as possible to
the sea and then secondly indeed farmers
in in europe overall use a lot of water
and they they are cut off which of
course means that they will have less
produce in many cases
but also households can do a lot um
every single household on it own
won't make such a difference but if you
multiply that by the number of people in
the number of households doing things
this can be significant just having
changing your your shower heads for
example with those that are water-saving
devices that saves already 50 of the
water you use for a shower there are a
lot of things and a lot of things
happening people have now two buttons on
they on their toilets and so on so they
use much less water than in the past
and of course things that are seen as
luxury things like washing your car
every week now or making sure that that
the grass is as green as it can be
uh that are of course things that are
yeah
for reasonable people out of scope now
all right thank you for that advice and
thank you for coming on to the program
today you're welcome thank you very much